So one of the really lovely things that you can do is look for the past and then
say,
well,
how does that manifest itself today?
And one of my favorite examples is the whites to your eyes.
So chimpanzees have brown eyes,
the Sclera around the cornea.
Ours are white.
Why would you do that?
Well then advertises the direction of your gaze.
Why would you advertise the direction as you gaze?
Because what that says is it on average as a human,
when I look over there and see something,
I want you to know that I saw it.
You and I are probably going to cooperate to help us achieve whatever the goal
is that I just encountered.
A chimp wants to hide it from its fellow chimps because it's competitive,
right?
On average,
whatever the hell is over there,
you're not going to help me get it right.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're going to make it harder for me to get it.
The chimps ever do that?
Hmm.
Amazingly,
amazingly groupers,
an Octopi hunt together and they do that.
The groupers and Octopi work together.
So the group will be over the Great Barrier Reef.
And the fish is gone in and he goes to the octopus and he goes it right there.
No one reason he doesn't give a shit about the octopus of course.
But if the occupants goes to get it and doesn't get it,
it's going to come out in the groupers.
Got It.
Cooperation always works better than working on your own.
Right.
Wow.
So is there real evidence that shows that the whites of our eyes developed in
order to indicate which way
we're looking at?
Well,
in all these cases,
all we can do is say,
let's do a little file,
a genetic analysis.
Who's got it and who does it?
We're the only great ape with whites to their eyes.
So 90
this here's an octopus that's chillin.
And is that a grouper?
No,
it's a weird looking for to spot it,
I guess.
I don't know.
Cause you to fall.
Look up.
They really pretty,
it looks like a coral trout to me.
Oh Man.
So what do I know?
Look how pretty that octopuses too.
Yeah,
they,
they're really sad and fucking love octopus.
They can change colors like that.
Yeah.
We've gone down massive rabbit holes with these things for hours at a time.
Look at it.
It's changing right now is we're watching him.
So He's,
he's sitting there waiting and the fish tries to get out and the art yet
and the group like a scratch.
Got You.
Yeah.
That's really cool.
The way they have the good sense to work
together.
Look at the octopus is mad.
It's getting dark or happy or how cool his skin is.
How it just changes and morphs as you're looking at it.
That is so bizarre.
What a crate.
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't know that they could do this until my friend Remy Warren came on the
podcast and he,
uh,
had a television show called Apex Predator.
And within on the show they would study,
uh,
the various ways these animals would hunt and the way they would,
you know,
all there,
there are different adaptations to their environment,
all the different ways that they would use the environment.
And,
and he would try to mimic those different ways.
And one of the things that they studied was octopus and,
uh,
what's that other fish?
That's like it.
The cuddle fish,
which is also the octopus is using this clamshell.
What is he doing?
He's lounging.
Picked it up.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
Oh my God.
The octopus is climbing inside of clam shell and then he it,
that is bananas.
There's a BBC blue planet where it shows the octopus picking up all that random
shrapnel when there's a shark coming after it and it covers itself like a big
ball.
And then sharks
keeps going.
Wow.
They're super smart Octopi.
Well they eat sharks.
You ever see that one?
There was a video where they found,
um,
this aquarium was having an issue with sharks were disappearing.
They couldn't figure out what was going on.
And uh,
they put a camera inside the aquarium and it turned out that the octopus was a
waiting,
just chilling on the rocks till the sharks came by and they would snatch him and
eat him.
Watch this.
It's really cool to watch.
He's like,
dude,
to do to who?
Me Don't bother with me.
I'm just a piece of coral.
I'm just hanging out here being
like,
and cause he looks exactly even in texture like the coral,
which is so fascinating.
But when they found this,
they were stunned.
They had no idea that octopus could do that.
Could not only did they could do that,
but that they would eat a shark.
And that's a big fight.
Fuck man.
It's not though.
You want to squeeze these emails said first,
but it's an easy fight I looks like is the thing about octopus though too?
They could sacrifice a technical and it just grows back.
Really.
No big deal.
It's annoying.
But yeah,
I don't even know if it's annoying.
I mean we're just guessing,
right?
So there's a fascinating animal
twisting them up.
There's an amazing case in Australia where a cooling brown is a biologist had
cuddle fish in his tank and they can signal like an Octopi octopus.
They can do whatever color.
And in this tank he's got a bunch of females on one side,
a bunch of males in the other.
So mail goes in between them and he signals to different sides of his body.
He shows a female's,
he's male.
But he shows the males that he's female.
So they want attack him for a sidling up to the fee.
Yeah.
What,
how smart is that?
It's weird.
It's weird that they split off from us hundreds of millions of years ago.
Like as closely related to celery basically.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
But they're so smart and their eyes are similar to ours and like,
hmm.
In the the development,
okay.
Actually it's the opposite.
So there our eyes are poorly designed.
There's a very well designed,
so our eyes have all the detecting stuff is in its own way.
It's backwards.
And so the light comes in and has to pass all the cellular bodies before it can
get picked up by the detectors.
There's aim in the proper direction.
So the shit isn't in the way.
And we have this blind spot because the big thing,
the,
the nerve connection,
they don't,
there's comes in from the back where it belongs.
So what that tells you is that yeah,
we both started out with some kind of randoms light sensitive spot and there's
happened to work much better if you want to turn it into an eyeball of in ours
did because evolution can always,
it only can start with what you've got but deserves work better because they
could see in water.
I mean is that the no,
I mean because there,
I think it's purely random that they don't have,
we do a great job of getting rid of the seg of their bodies that are in our way.
So what your eye does is it weakens all the time.
And so if anything's retinal stationary,
it's wiggling and equally with your eyeball,
you ignore it.
And so you don't even know.
You have your own blind spot,
you fill it in,
your brain does amazing to fix the problem.
If you have a piece of lint on your eye or something like that,
if they were literally attached to vent,
she would disappear.
And because your brain says,
well that's irrelevant.
And so you can't see your own blind spot unless you close one eye and then you
sit there with a neutral background,
you move your thumb across in literally your thumbnail disappears because that
spot is just being filled in by whatever the background is.
And what happens with the octopus,
it doesn't have that problem because our nerve ending creates a blind spot by
being on the wrong side.
There's,
it comes in from the back and so the whole thing works beautifully.
They don't have to deal with the blind spot.
Would that be as effective though in the world that we live in?
Yeah,
it's a water area irrelevant.
It's purely,
it happenstance that the light sensitive pit that they had started to get
innovated properly from the back and ours didn't.
And then as ours evolved into an,
I mean,
of course we don't know.
This is just,
but as far as evolved to an I,
we just had to find ways around the problem that all the fancy structures that
we now need in front of it or in the way does anything have an eye like an
octopus that lives on land?
Great question.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
See,
I read something about eyes that they think that I got shit information,
prominent memory,
that they have an amazing memory.
All these shows,
these still sore away.
That's too many shows,
man.
I don't have any memory anymore.
So it's like full.
Yeah.
Like I'm not a hoarder.
Like my house is filled with the boxes of shit that I don't need.
That's how brains work,
but I'm afraid it is how brains work,
right?
Yeah.